julian wie hast du die pressekonferenz
jetzt erlebt ich habe den ganzen tag
eigentlich als eine art von verwirrspiel
mit einem hauch von sozialistischer
mangelverwaltung rhetorik unserer
bundesregierung erlebt ich muss ehrlich
sagen ich weiß bei vielen nicht mehr was
eigentlich noch erlaubt ist oder was mir
die kanzlerin ich sage es mal so noch
erlaubt was uns unsere region noch
erlaubt was der unterschied zwischen
selbst test- und schnell test ist wovon
sie davon genug gekauft hat wovon sie
davon zu wenig gekauft hat ob es die
überhaupt gibt ob ich mir die woanders
besorgen soll und dann abrechnen soll
nämlich die rechnung schicke ich
verborgen weil den versuch machen oder
am 8 märz wir sind schnell test ein
schnelltest nach meiner kenntnis sind
sie auch gar nicht einzeln verpackt aber
ich versuche es trotzdem mal in der
apotheke zu kaufen und dann die rechnung
an ich weiß nicht wen sparen oder das
kanzleramt zu schicken ist was da heute
uns vorgeführt worden ist war ein
solches wer mir vor ich glaube vier
wochen schon einmal natürlich ganz so
spielt der stunde gesprochen und da war
ich schon entsetzt und ich hatte mir für
heute vorgenommen etwas konstruktives zu
sagen weil wir jetzt von der kanzlei
gehört haben wir seien in einer in eine
neue phase eingetreten und
möglicherweise in eine phase der
hoffnung
ich hoffe nur noch dass diese regierung
gewalt durch eine neue ersetzt wird ich
kann es nicht mehr anders sagen was dort
abgeliefert wird was dort vorgeführt
wird was heute bei diesen tests
vorgeführt worden ist das vom
flächendeckenden testen nicht geredet
worden ist sondern dass zugesagt worden
ist jetzt weiß man nicht ob es gibt und
das angebot ist jetzt jeder bürger darf
pro woche einen test abrechnen aber ich
weiß gar nicht bei wem und ich meinen
denn dazu mein ganz konkretes beispiel
um sich effektiv nach allen studien
diesem moment auf der welt gibt zu
schützen und andere zu schützen brauche
ich zwei tests pro woche ich bekomme vom
viertreichste land der welt
einem japan emi und allen versprechung
also die elfte wird es die ich als
bürger pro woche brauche und dann muss
ich sie abrechnen um meine mitmenschen
zu schützen
das war alles heute ein absoluter
totalausfall der mündete in zu würdigen
die kein normaler mensch mehr begreift
man höhepunkt war als michael müller
sagte eine din a4 seite eine din a4
seite das erinnert mich ein bisschen an
die stoiber rede dass steigen sie quasi
am flughafen münchen in den hauptbahnhof
ein
das war alles für mich ein spiel wie es
mir niemals hätte ausmalen können und
dann das was mich am meisten mitgenommen
hat muss ich sagen und tatsächlich auch
empört ist die art und weise wie diese
regierung sich für das was du da gerade
ab wie verlobt wie sie uns erzählt es
ist viel erreicht von wie makeln uns
noch mal erzählt was vor einem jahr war
und vergisst was sie in den letzten drei
vier monaten historisch ich muss es
wirklich mal so klar sein historisch
vergeigt hat die bundeskanzlerin nach
allem was sie erreicht hat nach allem
was sie getan hat danach ein was sie
geleistet hat in den 16 jahren ihrer
kanzlerschaft wird mit diesem total
debakel bei impfen bei dem ausweg aus
dieser pandemie beim testen der in die
geschichtsbücher eingehen
bemerken sie kämpft da gerade um ihre
legacy um ihre rolle in den
geschichtsbüchern
die wird nicht milde urteilen und
vielleicht ein letzter punkt die
bundesregierung hat uns nicht zu sagen
was wir zu tun und zu lassen haben die
bundesregierung hat die umstände
herzustellen unter dem wir leben können
die bundesregierung hat die umstände
herzustellen unter den geschäfte wieder
geöffnet sein können und uns nichts zu
sagen vielleicht reden wir dann später
noch mal über wusste
die bundesregierung hat vollkommen aus
den augen verloren was ihre rolle
gegenüber dem bürger ist die
bundesregierung ist bereit uns jetzt
wieder vertrauen zu schicken
entschuldigung wir schenken unserer
regierung vertrauen oder nicht und nicht
die bundesregierung die bürger diese
regierung hat vollkommen aus den augen
verloren wie das verhältnis zwischen
wlan und regierung in unserer
wunderbaren demokratie und was ich heute
gehört habe hat mich nur noch entsetzt